what if all straw hats fought your five
Luffy together would they be able to
defeat him or would he absolutely crush
them well to better understand this
let's quickly see how each member would
fare against their captain in battle is
there any form of Luffy they can defeat
individually and is there any member
that can defeat year 4 or gear 5 Luffy
for example Usopp has already fought
Luffy once at Water 7 and we all know
how that went for straw hat sniper based
on this it's clear that pre-time skip
usop has no chance against Luffy but
what about after the time skip does usop
have any chance then well not really
although usop got noticeably stronger
after his training and added pop greens
into his Arsenal he still has no real
chance of contending with Luffy if the
two did actually battle the only thing
usop could do is keep his distance and
try to hit him with sniper shots however
Luffy's observation hockey is way too
advanced and this wouldn't pose the
slightest problem for him you could
argue that usop himself also has this
type of hockey but to be honest I don't
see a way that would help him in this
matchup I'll go as far as to say that
current usop can't even defeat pre-time
skip Gear 2 Luffy I may be
underestimating Rusev a bit here but
considering that Luffy managed to defeat
lueno and contend with Rob Lucci in this
form I just can't imagine usup defeating
him Luffy vs Chopper although it may not
seem like it Chopper has achieved some
notable Feats pre-time skip like
defeating gadatsu and cp9 agent kumadori
however after the time skip he suffered
the same fate as USA very slight power
Improvement and lagging behind his
fellow crewmates on top of that the
straw hats doctor has zero understanding
of hockey and there are no signs that he
will learn it anytime soon the only
actual threat to Luffy would be his
strongest transformation monster point
but even then can he do anything against
his captain well if it's pre-time skip
Luffy ending isn't using any gears sure
I think he'd be able to defeat him
nevertheless if Luffy activates Gear 2
there is just no way Chopper could keep
up with its speed he'd be crushed in no
time due to his endurance he definitely
able to stay alive a bit longer than
usop but at the end of the day he should
just stick to being a doctor although
Chopper couldn't contend with Luffy on
his own he'll definitely be much more
useful at the end of the video when all
straw hats engage Luffy together Luffy
vs Brooke here is when things start to
get interesting when Brooke was
initially introduced it seemed like he
was just a weird funny guy who couldn't
fight at all but that was far from the
truth Brooke turned out to be a very
experienced and strong Soldier well not
as strong as some of the legends of the
series but no small fry either most
importantly he is really experienced as
he was a pirate even before gold D Roger
went out to the Sea so is there any form
of Luffy he can defeat well due to his
incredible speed I think he would
actually be the first character on this
list to hold his own against Luffy's
pre-time skip Transformations now this
doesn't mean he'll win for sure but he
definitely put up a great fight and
survived far longer than the other
characters so far of course it goes
without saying that gear for Luffy would
crush him in seconds Luffy vs num Nomi
being this high on this list might seem
unrealistic but if you really think
about it she has actually pretty
powerful recently after the time skip
her main weapon climb attacked got some
very powerful upgrades and recently it
even became sentient thanks to Zeus
fusing with it and amplifying its power
nami's greatest achievement is bringing
down ulti a beast pirate worth 400
million bellies proving just how strong
she really became so how would she fare
against Luffy well due to everything I
mentioned so far she should be able to
defeat Luffy's pre-time skip gear
Transformations however if you still
don't believe this just remember that
Nami also knows Lupi's personality and
since he is not really the smartest guy
out there she probably managed to
manipulate him to some extent and
eventually defeat him when it comes to
Luffy's more powerful Transformations
she stands absolutely no chance against
them gear 4 and gear 5 Luffy could
defeat her in hundreds of ways but the
most interesting one would definitely be
just to catch her Thunderbolt mid-flight
and throw it back at her same as he did
against kaido okay with nami covered we
finally got to some of the strongest
crew members and it will be very
interesting to see how they would stack
against Luffy Luffy vs Frankie the
shipwright of the crew Frankie spent the
time skip researching and improving his
inventions using schematics obtained
from an old lab of Dr vegapunk however
based on everything he has done since
the time skip he doesn't seem to have
acquired any groundbreaking Powers
Frankie is far more useful in a group
battle as he can support his crewmates
with his inventions and if he had to
fight Luffy on his own it wouldn't be a
great experience for him using general
Frankie to protect himself and radical
beams to attack from a long range
Frankie should be able to defeat Luffy's
weaker forms however same as the other
characters so far he is not nearly
strong enough to take on tier 4 in
battle if Luffy was to fight him
seriously Frankie would be crushed Luffy
vs Robin Robin's current Bounty is
almost 1 billion bellies and while
that's mostly due to her knowledge about
poneoglyphs she isn't Weak by any means
this is especially true after wano where
she got a very strong power-up called
demoniaflure which enabled her to defeat
black Maria who had a bounty of 480
million bellies same as Frankie Robin
should be able to defeat any pre-time
skip version of Luffy relatively easily
in a battle against are for Luffy she
could briefly hold him down with
multiple arms using her devil fruit and
then slam him with the Fishman karate
technique admittedly it would be quite
difficult to subdue this version of
Luffy but if she ambushes him with
enough arms she should be able to land a
few hits on him it was revealed that she
also knows how to create clones of
herself which would serve as a good way
to distract Luffy however even with all
of this Robin doesn't really have a way
to keep Luffy down permanently so even
if it takes him a bit more time he'll
easily defeat her what's interesting is
that a lot of Robin's abilities work
really well in combination with other
straw hats so it'll surely be incredible
to see how she will use them at the end
of the video when all straw hats engage
gear 5 Luffy together Luffy vs jinbe
jinbei is a master of Fishman karate a
former warlord and the Knights of the
sea can he be the first character on the
list to finally defeat gear 4 Luffy
despite not possessing any devil fruit
Powers it's important to mention that
jimbei is the first character so far to
have two types of hockey Armament and
observation which would greatly help him
in his battle against gear for Luffy
furthermore both of them have incredible
endurance with Luffy fighting katakuri
for 12 hours and jinbei fighting Ace for
five days straight based on this it
would surely be a long battle with many
injuries on both sides but who wins at
the end well let's look at it like this
Luffy defeated doflamingo in this form
do you really think jinbei would be able
to do the same obviously not and this is
the main reason why I think loopy would
win at the end but it definitely
wouldn't be easy before we explain how
Luffy's right hand man would fare
against him let's first cover a battle
between Luffy and Sanji Sanji is Luffy's
left-hand man and the future pirate king
definitely shouldn't take this fight
lightly you all know how strong Sanji is
especially after wano where he learned
his new powerful ability called Ifrit
jambe he also managed to defeat Queen
one of the strongest members of the
Beast pirates with a bounty of over 1
billion bellies due to his offensive
fighting style Sanji would engage Luffy
immediately and start dealing serious
damage with his kicks also since Sanji
is arguably the fastest crew member here
for Luffy would have a very hard time
dodging his attack Luffy would most
likely have to fight in his boundman
variation in order to survive some of
sanji's powerful kicks one more
important thing about the fourth gear is
that it significantly affects Luffy's
body this means that if Sanji can stay
alive until Luffy reaches his limit he
could easily finish him off since Luffy
would be completely defenseless so can
Sanji pull it off is he the first Straw
Hat to defeat gear for Luffy yes I think
Sanji could achieve this with mid to
high difficulty but unfortunately that's
exactly where sanji's luck ends as when
Luffy enters his newest gear 5 form he
would absolutely crush him there is no
way Sanji can even remotely contend with
this Beast he would lose in mere minutes
Luffy vs Zorro Zorro is without a doubt
the second strongest member of the straw
hat crew he is also the only character
in The Crew besides Luffy to have all
three types of hockey Zoro did some
incredible things in wano like blocking
Emperor's combined attack injuring kaido
and even defeating King he is surely the
one who will give Luffy the absolute
toughest fight so far and there is one
important reason for this since Zora
uses swords and cutting attacks to fight
is Luffy's natural weakness using his
three sword style each of zoro's attacks
would be deadly for Luffy and he'd have
no other options than to dodge every
single one undoubtedly Zoro can defeat
every single version of Luffy before
wano this also includes gear 4 Luffy who
are the reasons we previously mentioned
shouldn't pose that much of a problem
for current Zorro so what about the sun
god Luffy can our favorite swordsman do
anything against him well yes and no
firstly it's important to mention that
Luffy is still vulnerable to cutting
attacks even in this Godly form and if
Sorrel can find some openings he
actually has a good chance of dealing
some damage to it however even if Zorro
has a few things going his way in this
fight Luffy's abilities in this form are
just too ridiculous for our swordsman to
handle Luffy wins this low to mid
difficulty but definitely not without
some injuries Luffy versus the straw
hats alright as you've seen so far no
single crew member has a chance of
defeating Luffy but what if all of them
attacked gear 5 Luffy together who would
be victorious in this epic match-up the
closest to a full team up against one
individual the straw hats ever had was
against Orr's on Thriller bark although
each member was considerably weaker than
they currently are this team up
showcased their incredible teamwork and
chemistry something that would further
help them in this fight is the fact they
are all familiar with most of Luffy's
fighting styles meaning they could plan
and prepare a strategy beforehand most
of you probably forgot about this but
straw hats have one technique that can
put gear 5 Luffy down in a matter of
seconds which one you may ask giant
robot big emperor of course this all
depends on if Robin will go through with
it this time okay in all seriousness
leading the charge would obviously be
Zoro Sanji and jimbe they would probably
attack from three different angles to
confuse Luffy and make it harder for him
to dodge Brooke and Frankie could act
similarly but instead of close combat
they could use radical beam and killing
sword attacks and not give Luffy any
time to rest while all this is happening
Nami Chopper and Robin will watch
closely and try to spot some of Luffy's
weak points in case Luffy transforms
into a giant using his new abilities
monster Point Chopper General Frankie
and Robin's gigantic fluid should be
able to hold him down okay so the best
Contender to land the finishing blow on
Luffy would obviously be Zorro since as
we already mentioned his fighting style
is really good against Luffy's fruit
however this won't be easy and it would
require straw hats to weaken Luffy
significantly and hold him down for at
least a few seconds this would make an
opening for Zorro to land a precise
finishing strike with his new sword
enlach so can they manage to pull this
off well based on everything these
characters achieved throughout the show
I am certain they would manage to do it
some of the weaker members may lose
their life in the process but in the end
Luffy will be defeated by his crew and
there is not much he can do to avoid it
click on this video where we explained
52 secret things you didn't know about
One Piece go on click it